[Music]
our first speaker
is neil richardson from ursa labs
thanks
hey all right so i'm going to talk today
about
the aero project both the aero r package
as well as the broader apache arrow
project that it's within
um i've got a link to the slides there
and i've also tweeted it
at npr you can also tweet us or follow
us
at apache arrow for more news
don't worry if you don't copy this down
i've got a link to the slide on every
slide
link to the slides on every slide so um
before i jump in to talk about era i
first wanted to introduce
who i am and who ursa labs is
i'm the maintainer of the r package for
arrow
i'm also the engineering director with
ursa labs and we
are a non-profit that is oriented at
funding open data tools we're sponsored
by our studio
and a number of other companies and we
are focused on the apache aero
ecosystem if you're interested in
learning more about us
or have follow-up questions from the
talk we're going to be in the
expo hall the yosemite room at 3 45
today
so so generally when i tell people that
i work
on the aero project in data science
they're like oh yeah arrow that's that's
awesome i've heard of that that's really
cool
what is arrow
and there is a lot of things and that
kind of defines a simple
explanation but one way that i like to
frame it in terms particularly with what
it means for the r community
is it it's a foundation for the next
generation
of data frames as anyone who's worked
with bigger data in
r has surely experienced you know r is
great and there's lots of powerful tools
and really expressive ways of getting
work done in r
but once you start getting data sets
that are bigger than memory on your
laptop
you have to do some special tricks to
make it work
often you have data sets that's where
the data split into multiple files
and you can work with this but it's
again it's not as natural
and you know many data sets have more
complex data types than your base you
know character
numeric factor and what have you and
and of course the more data we have the
more we want to throw all of our
hardware at it
and these are possible in r but it's
just not how r itself was designed
well we're in good company these are not
just problems uh
of r so uh wes mckinney who uh
created the pandas library for python
ran similar challenges there and um
you know constraints on memory and on
data types and
and whatnot and so uh so wes and some
others
uh from the data community created uh
the apache aero project in 2016.
uh you may have experienced the feather
package which came out of some of the
initial
explorations there the prototype of the
arrow format
which makes it really easy to write data
frames in r and read them in
pandas and vice versa and the idea was
to
draw on all these lessons we have from
from r and from pandas and from data the
database community
and build the next generation of data
frame tools that were
not tied to a specific language or
implementation
so arrow fundamentally is two two
classes of things so first is the format
this is the specification of how
bits are arranged in memory it's
columnar and it's
independent of any language and then
there's implementations
or bindings to other implementations in
currently 11 languages
so the python library and the r package
both point they both bind to the c plus
plus library which is where a lot of the
development happens
so the error our package has been on
cran
since august we're about to do a new
release
i'm hoping next week this will be up on
cran cran willing
and um so some of the things i'm going
to show you right now i'm going to
show a little code and talk about a few
other features
they're not on cran right now if you're
interested in checking them out
right now not right now but after i'm
done talking i guess
we build nightly versions of the
packages that you can download
and there's a a repository that you just
you can point at and then do install
packages against that
don't worry i'll show these links again
and again they're also on the slides if
you want to follow along
i mentioned code so let me do this let
me show you some code
i hope that's big enough um so one of
the cool features that's coming out
in the upcoming release of the error
package
are is the data sets api and this lets
us point at
a directory of files and then treat them
as a single
entity and then be able to do dplyr on
them
so dplyr is not a dependency of the
error package it is an optional
suggest dependency so we have to load
both of them if we want to use this
feature
i've got i'm gonna look at um
some of the new york city taxi data i've
got about i got over 10 years of data
split into files per month
um and you see what's in the directory
here i've got 125 files so
10 years and uh five months and each
directory
is year month and then a parquet file
with those in them
this is a lot of data uh two billion
rows
and uh and so even with these compressed
files it's
37 gigabytes of data so more than i can
read
into memory and hold the memory in this
laptop
so um the new version of the error
package has this function open dataset
so let me just point at a directory
and i can also specify information about
the
path segments of those files that are in
there so in this case
the paths are year and month and so that
corresponds useful data
in our data set so when i scan all of
the files and inspect the metadata of
those parquet files
and get the common schema of them i also
you can see through here i also get year
and month added as
essentially virtual columns there and
then i can use that in my queries
and importantly i can filter against
that which means i don't have to
actually
load all those files in order to know
that for example in this case
only files that are in that 2015
directory are going to be
have data for 2015. so i can run this
you know fairly so basic uh d plier
do some filtering selecting columns and
then do
i was just the median tip percentage on
these rides
and so i just scanned two billion rows
in under four seconds
uh and and here's my table
um so let me
jump back to slides um for those of you
following along on the slides this is
actually a link here to
that notebook that's also online so you
can check it out check out that later
there's also a vignette in the new
version of the package that walks
through this
and and talks a little bit more about
the feature so
with this this data sets feature
we're able to point out a directory and
we can use parallel processing i didn't
have to
tell it to do it it's just taking
advantage of all the cpu it can
and we're able to make efficient queries
on this and all the work is pushed down
into these individual individual
file chunks so i don't need to be able
to read the whole data set into memory
in order to to query with it there's a
lot more planning to do on this this
year so if this is interesting to you
stay tuned um more file formats uh
cloud storage so that i could point at a
an s3 bucket for example and do the same
type operation
uh just just as smoothly as well as
faster aggregation and c
plus plus i mentioned parquet along the
way
i believe the error package is the only
one on crayon now that lets you read and
write parquet files
if you're not familiar parquet is a
common
columnar binary file format using a lot
of data warehouse
data warehousing etl systems
and the really cool thing about it is
that it supports
multiple forms of compression and
encoding so you can get really small
files that are also really fast
to load and work with we did some
benchmarking of this
a few months ago and you can see that
the
with this example file that we're
looking at here the read time is
is around in the same ballpark as all
these other readers but the file size
is an order of magnitude smaller so if
you're not using parquet check it out
there's some cool stuff there
so i think i'm excited about this stuff
i think there's a lot of cool
work in the new version the aero package
coming out
and that we're working on this year but
there are lots of ways to solve these
problems this is r of course so there's
many solutions every problem
and you know you could cobble together
something from
a number of different packages to solve
the you know memory mapping
or multiple files or you know point out
a database or any number of solutions
for this
and those are totally valid and i'm not
going to try to
convince you that you should use arrow
instead of doing that
what i want to talk about now though is
uh why i think the aero project is
uh is unique and why it's worth uh
following and considering for whether
it's appropriate for your projects
so the first thing is that you know i
just i demoed one
thing here but the aero apache arrow
project is much larger than that
uh and one measure of that is the number
of contributors we've got
uh around 400 contributors maybe more or
less
and it's a steadily growing number as
you can see over the course of the
history of the project here you know
we're picking up about two new
contributors
every week so this is a growing
community lots of people adding things
to make
the software better make the software
better for you and this you know
in contrast with uh you know another
project where maybe you've got one core
maintainer or maybe two
um you know the i think the
sustainability as well of a project that
has this type of foundation uh is really
good second as i mentioned there's a lot
more going on than just
the features i demoed in r these
projects here are part of the aero
broader era project and they don't
currently have
our bindings hopefully this year maybe
we'll get some of those
one that's really cool just to highlight
one is flight
which is a client server framework for
shipping columnar
data around the network and some folks
have been using it have found it to be
really fast and performant so i'm really
excited about
seeing that in r as well
so uh there are lots of contributors
there are lots of projects that are also
already using
arrow and i don't say this to say well
everyone else is doing it so you should
do it
but what it means is that there's
a lot of other projects that have a
vested interest in
the growth and health of arrow and in
making it better
and also if you're using some of these
other projects
arrow improves interoperability so it's
it is language independent
the format is language independent and
so it makes it easier
for you to efficiently get data in and
out of
whatever database or system
one example of this uh in r
is with the sparkliar package javier
who's
talking next is gonna he uh added
features
uh to sparkly r to take advantage of
arrow
uh apache spark database can emit arrow
data
and by adding support for reading that
in r
just by loading the arrow package now
you just get a 40x speed up
when pulling data out of spark you don't
have to do anything else
so i think this there's a lot of
opportunities for things like this
and like i said if this is if this is
interesting to you don't leave after i'm
done talking
i know you're all here just for me um
but javier is going to talk a bit more
about things in that ecosystem
i've met said this a few times but arrow
is
language independent language agnostic
and i think this has a number of nice
properties for us in the in the art
community
so uh unlike use saving an rdata file or
something
uh if you write using arrow
the the data that you write is
immediately readable by people in python
or in java
or rus or go or javascript or whatever
and so that really helps us with
collaboration with people that
for whatever reason aren't using r and
it also
gives us an on-ramp to access all these
other projects
that uh the use arrow as their core
representation
but that but that are not implemented in
r
um so one thing i'm hoping to get out
this year at some point
is support with reticulate for aerodata
types
so this is just hypothetical code
because this
hasn't been released yet but for one
example
nvidia has a this project the rapids
project and they have a number of
uh largely python based projects that
use gpus
gpu acceleration for machine learning
this one here in this example qdf is a
data frame library that uses gpus
and so with reticulate and arrow we can
just we should be able to just
do our work using qdf and then continue
with our workflow
in r as as if it were in r
so again not in the package don't run
this code right now
but uh hopefully very soon
all right uh so if this sounds
interesting to you uh
i have some offers for you first thing
you can do
to get involved is of course try out the
package
um i mentioned it's on crayon
it's uh it's if you use a conda it's
also we also have a conda recipe
uh here's a link again to our our
nightly repositories
we build uh binary packages for mac and
windows as well as c plus plus binaries
for a number of linux distributions
so that you can just point at our
repository and download the latest
development build
that way uh i mentioned linux
if anyone here has tried installing
arrow previously on linux and
felt frustrated because you had to
install system packages or whatever i
see some heads nodding yes sorry
but as of the current release this
should no longer be an issue the current
release
of the upcoming release uh will just
work on linux with no
uh system dependencies required and if
you're really curious to learn more
about that we have a vignette that shows
how that works
um i mentioned our dev builds uh i
i encourage you if you want to use the
latest arrow uh and again we
we only do uh crane releases every three
months or so so
uh if you want to check out what's going
on in between those
uh which is often a lot uh you should
try
our uh our nightly builds uh i would not
recommend
using install github uh for arrow just
because of the c
plus building stuff that it has to deal
with if you use our nightly builds you
won't have to worry with that
when you use arrow tell us about it uh
you know we are
actively working hard to improve it
and there is zero chance we have
anticipated every
uh use case or weird data shape out
there
i say we're not in a judgmental way
there's you know
lots of interesting data out there and
um
so tell us about it or we'd love to we'd
love to make it better
and of course this is open source this
is community supported software and we
can't do it
uh except with contributors from users
like you
so uh feel free to uh
we will probably if you write an issue
we will probably ask you if you are
interested in submitting a full request
for it please do
and uh you know some of the projects can
be very highly technical
um but uh other parts of it are much
more accessible and we'll do our best to
provide on-ramps to to uh to help
contrib people who want to contribute
documentation improvements totally fair
game and i'm sure there's plenty of room
for that
finally you can also sponsor ursa labs
so as i mentioned we are a non-profit
organization funded by a number of
companies most
uh first among others by our studio uh
as well as a number of other companies
and uh this lets us do some of the
important things
kind of like what jj was talking about
in the keynote this morning of having a
dedicated
team that is working to improve and
foster the health of the
community and it lets us get off the
ground some of these bigger projects
and getting a critical mass together to
to kick off the data sets or
the query engine that we're built
working on this year and whatnot uh
that's really difficult to do
in a you know pure volunteer open source
project
uh where people are contributing the
time that they can
and also we take seriously the
the open source community and our role
within it as
uh kind of maintainers and helping to
make it easier for other people to
contribute
so uh info ursalabs.org uh if you're
interested in this
and also i don't know if this link works
yet uh but
it looks like it might we are hopefully
coming up on github sponsors so you can
just click there and give us money that
way too
thanks a lot as i mentioned i'll take
some questions now
you can tweet at us or follow us at
apache arrow and that's me at npr
and we'll be in about an hour over in
the yosemite room after this
session if you have any other further
questions thanks a lot
so we do have time for a few questions
um if you haven't discovered it already
you can also submit
questions on slido.com using the code
hexagon
that gives you a chance not only to
submit questions but vote on other
people's questions as well
so does anybody have a question
there are a bunch in slido's given the
room first
all right well i'll go right to slide
with them so one of the first questions
we
one of the most popular questions on
slido the most popular question with 10
votes is
data table is multi-threaded and very
fast what
are the performance metrics between
arrow and data table
so it's kind of it's not really a fair
comparison
there are different have different goals
so
what i just showed here of
querying against a multi-file data set
in parquet i
i haven't tried data table i don't know
if it supports multiple file data sets
if it does that'd be interesting um
parquet reading i think
the goals of what we're doing in um
an arrow are slightly different from
what data tables goals are
but one of the things that's very
important to us is performance obviously
and one of our goals for the year is to
put up
you know benchmarking information so
that when we have questions like this i
can give a hard number instead of uh
not so javier if you want to step up and
start getting ready we'll do
another question from the audience
i just wanted to say that i was testing
that the other day and
on some very large but very simply
structured data sets
arrows was reading and writing about
twice as fast
cool but on but on relatively small data
sets data table was quite a bit faster
all right good to know thank you
um another popular question is is
feather dead and there was a related
question around whether feather was
appropriate for long-term storage or not
excellent questions so um you know we
view
uh feather as kind of like the first
version of the
arrow format uh standard it has
it's very effective but it also has a
number of limitations in terms of the
data types it
supports so
what we're looking to do is to have kind
of a 2.0 version of feather
that is essentially the arrow format
going forward
we'll be there are a number of things
that we're working on this year
around uh addressing that sort of
stability of the
era format and its long-term
applications uh we've got our 1.0
release coming up
uh hopefully in the coming months right
west
it's not dead yeah and um
no not at all dead and um you know i
think there'll be an evolution
going forward but uh it's not it's not
dead
excellent thank you another round of
applause for neil please thank you
[Music]